great year for video drops but the worse
than bad video games Peter brand reviews
editor of GameSpot calm you took over
the the the reins for mr. van Award
earlier this year it turns out there was
a lot of bad games came out and yeah
which my favorite part of this is
actually that you reviewed quite a lot
of them yeah I think three
yeah real stinkers so Jesus I even this
tier of all games that got under five
out of ten so four and below on GameSpot
calm I can't even talk about all of them
because there are so many of them but
let's rattle rattled for a few first of
all a wonderful a three out of ten year
Tony Hawk's Pro Skater five Peter brand
you reviewed that game why was that game
not better so there are moments when I
was playing Tony Hawk five where I felt
like it it like captured the essence of
the old games but gaming has moved on
and rather than like change with the
times and and take you know lessons
learned from years of development after
the fact they sort of just like cobbled
together some weird features and put it
on top of this really really bear Tony
Hawk experience and they didn't do it in
clean away there are a lot of glitches
it's it's it was broken it wasn't
challenging in the right ways and it
just wasn't fun like after five minutes
I was done with it they didn't give me a
reason to actually care and like you
know what at this point like Tony Hawk
is kind of old news like we've played
this style of game many times over Tony
Hawk HD is still a thing and better than
this game I mean a good Tony Hawk game
would probably have been pretty cool to
play it would have been great is a good
and this one sort of it seems like it's
kind of good every now and again I could
give you shades of what you remember but
then instantly sort of gives you look at
how do you see how the screen is shaking
when he's grinding like that is a
logical decision somebody made you spent
half is like the first time I came up I
was like oh that's like a novel little
level and then it comes up like you know
four different levels on there like
slightly during every stage you go to
has the same challenges
it's just cookie cutter crap what a
shame and I glanced over at your TV it
looked really fun but I think I was just
glancing over as you do very briefly
yeah
the grind stomp thing is like one of the
worst controlled decisions I've seen in
in recently yeah I got rid of any
ability to like buffer a thing and
actually like make a clean combo I know
they gave me reviewed around about time
as well I think four to ten chibi-robo
zip lash yes I got them I didn't know
what the hell this is so you played this
little robot that sort of has like a is
like a extension cord used as a
grappling hook okay and so you get
through these levels it's just like a
side-scrolling 2d platformer but the
game isn't challenging it's very easy
which isn't necessarily that bad but the
biggest problem I had at the game is
that your sole motivation is to go out
and collect like actual real-world candy
okay bring it back to people and they're
like boy I sure do love starbursts with
the five flavors that really tickle my
bugs
really yes I own is filled with
commercials on it and it is like okay
the gameplay is solid it's not great
it's not challenging but that part was
just stupid
John filthy filthy and another game that
came out relatively recently four out of
ten WWE 2k16 you have any know several
minutes at a friend's house okay how fun
was that I'm not too well-versed in
wrestling into general since like the
Nintendo 64 okay it is not a scholar of
the WWE Universe arted watching
wrestling sort of but the game it'll be
a lot of time to be watching for that's
what I hear oh you're gonna leave uphill
from here everyone's injured right now
but the game itself doesn't really feel
like feel great I don't I never knew
what I was doing even when I tried
learning several of the moves and the
controls I know a lot of people I think
I review was complaining about its kind
of arbitrary how close you need to be
someone how you actually like start
these moves and it felt pretty bad
biggest real air they've had in the game
ever oh these people a pretty low score
sadly four to ten on the spot cost a
game they got lower than not though came
out I feel was it in your opposed Devils
third it's only comment recently I was a
UK reviewers yes Sean Bell is Sean valve
three at a ten I hear that game is a
real piece of hot garbage yeah it's kind
of a tragic story too because apparently
takaki has been trying to make this
forever in oranged hands multiple times
in terms of publishers and ownership and
you know with that comes different
demands and I mean who knows where the
blame actually lies but yeah this game
did not pan out here we have Ivan right
6a - Ivan
yeah the most original character whoa
like what the hell are we looking at
here like a bozo were you game like what
imagination went into crafting that
character that's what I wanted somebody
saw prison-break also it's a Wii U game
I feel like at the end of its lifecycle
yeah it's a bit weird that it also got
it was such a massive delay between here
and Europe like it's it's almost a
wonderful or terrible critical reception
on a console too not many people are
buying these types of games especially
even Nintendo like when they're sending
out press releases to like or just like
you know like mailing lists stuff they
remind you of all the great games that
are coming out like the final paragraph
is like bullet point buried it oh no
speaking of weird stuff that was
released in Europe first Rory McIlroy
PGA Tour finally gets the honors
get away tiger I'm on the box
representing Northern Ireland three out
of ten tiny this is not a good golf game
I guess not
no it didn't look great I mean the
actual environments themselves looked
pretty shoddy something that's wrong
game wait really
let's just take a well you know any
players Rory McIlroy in this game look
at this game I'd give this game a bogey
a golf out of sports look look at that
looks pretty good
what do you call that guy like a caddy
the caddy that gosh master master
look at that look will he got it when he
got it when he got it when he got it go
three out of ten everything exactly a
game that somebody here on the couch has
played a game that was so bad that it's
been pulled from stores afros only home
to an Italian GameSpot Peter just wow in
a game full of hot guy in a year with
some hot garbage
and you've been the stinkies it's it's
one of the worst like finish
published games I've ever played both on
a tactical level on a design level and
just when it comes to just like oh wow
it was painful watching like as much
training as you did during Tony Hawk I
think maybe this was worse I just
remember watching it review it if you
just were the saddest I've ever seen I
don't know where to start like okay well
not even show in footage yeah we have to
show footage I need I need like s or
students we can because it's gonna give
people convulsion okay Afro Samurai is a
game has a combat system there's three
to three tiers in its combat system that
offers different fighting styles none of
them matter like cutscenes and halfway
through and gameplay goes but you still
have the audio from the cutscene going
and okay audio from the gameplay great
there's a scene where you're going to
try to find a man and the game's
justification is where do you go to find
men strip clubs so okay so there's a
strip club that's fun but the problem
when you're in the strip club it focuses
on a woman oh here we go sir out just
swinging back and forth for like ten
minutes
well at two minutes later this dude like
after she dies that calls her a [ __ ]
it's like oh my god like what is what is
this this game has nothing going on it
says what era did this game come out
it's horrible I mean I and because the
bad checkpoints did you have to redo
that scene like four times I had to redo
that psyche multiple times because there
is a boss fight that didn't actually
just describe how like what the rules
were
yeah so I didn't notice I was beating my
head against the wall for oh Jesus okay
oh yeah alright great
if it they set up this like huge town
they do this huge flyby and they're like
oh man like I'm gonna have to go explore
and then they put you right at the
doorstep of the place you need to get to
like this is a game of unrealized ideas
like unrefined
writing poor acting the best thing it
has is a soundtrack that is oh yeah
somewhat enjoyable and it's a real shame
so it soaked it in kids because this is
the only way you'll be able to play
experience out first time I to it's
available anymore
Kevin vine our before he left us for
greener pastures 3
and Godzilla yeah that game is trash to
quote a to quote a Peter Brown is ism it
is a trash game for garbage people
garbage game prescribers game for trash
people whatever what a shame
it's bad it's bad it's like look at it
yeah you're supposed to be Just Cause 3
basically right you're just like you're
just destroyed you're destroying the
city and like you know how it stops and
it stops and it stops yeah that's part
of the gameplay and they they put that
in on purpose so they could recreate
like the feel of the TV show ok where
things would slow down but instead of
being like entertaining it's just super
frustrating to walk long distances as
well there's that like lumbering yeah I
like that try again get : new birds
right here he moves so slow it's no bad
look at him look at this look at it yeah
just we don't even need us to talk just
watch this pile of garbage here we go
and that guy into top right on corner
he's named an animators cannot think the
metal Godzilla yeah speaking of weird
games baiser and carnage we finally got
to play Carmageddon reincarnation
Carmen we'll see reviewed her first for
the 10 has anyone played that one beta
yeah it's a technical mess but that's a
beta for you I don't know what what did
you say you remember no sure don't like
twisted metal or vigilante 8 no they're
not like car arena battlers like they
are there ok still a technical mess yeah
these are just racing games that like
you know like the original came out like
an early 90s it was all bloody and dark
okay oh my gosh yes a real shame that's
because I love some of these old classic
games and like some of them should
remain classics kind of like a great
game to come back but then just bad
excuse like there's like road rash is
like my stuff
why didn't come after all oh no she's oh
god yeah there you go go what's gonna
happen this is an official trailer I
think this is so weird
the Penguins almost out of like guys we
got a couple more to get through I got
three more here Austin Walker before he
joined Giant Bomb reviewed a bunch a
game for is he really like project cars
he was not so much fun of codenames oh
my god
that game for it attack I hate that game
when they announce it like only the e3
previous but you know like nine months
later
yeah they had like a big special special
presentation where they were like we're
gonna announce our new game and it was
codenamed steam and what's so
disappointing about codename steam is it
is a strategy like tactical turn-based
game by the Fire Emblem people yeah Fire
Emblem games are so good and coding seem
was such garbage and the whole idea of
like the American heroes teaming up was
kind of cool like Abraham Lincoln like
running a what running like a like what
is is like underground steam punk mafia
or whatever it was sounded cool but some
of the character is also really overtly
racist and the gameplay real bad yeah
yeah it tried to be like an ex-con light
yeah it's yeah no and and it's yeah like
it was slow it didn't the themes like
the themes in the artwork were just
immediately off-putting to me and the
gameplay added added no value it's in an
is a shame like it it's just it's like
curious footnote in the last year for a
Nintendo like no one talks about it
anymore
you know they made such a big deal about
it and just quietly yeah ugh yeah may
have to do it like a patch for it cuz
like the turns were too slow yes I
remember that you're right in this big
deal because the enemy enemy turns to
took too long so you could speed it up
like here's the mess a terrible mess
the lowest-scoring game on GameSpot calm
was earlier this year at dawn sauce with
ravenscry yeah remember that yeah I
remember reading so yeah ok the thing
that stood out to me you is the fact
that you had to press the X button like
multiple times to open a door like like
like it was just riddled with a logic or
mechanics I guess if it's stuck you got
a really really I mean this this looks
nice right but Missy you said it was
sexist Alexa um so I previewed the game
a couple years ago and I remember seeing
it when it came out it's just really
like gross and really sexual and like it
doesn't even do it and like a way that's
like that's like can like tip to the
plot or to character development it's
just there to be there and I think it's
I remember Don's review actually
highlighted that first yeah as well and
just technical problems around
just not like just incredibly
uninteresting yeah it's no Black Flag
it's no Black Flag no now play your
pirate game you got it
ravenscry there one at a ten on gang
spike on the last one to mention this
year
yowza I feel like this game we've gotten
even worse score four came out today
Justin Clark reviewed hatred for tired
eyes post alone I used like Oh postal
games I used to play there kind of like
dumb games on the kids this is like the
poor version of that which also I don't
know just was like super grossing you
know it's incredibly gross yeah
considering everything that's happened
this year with like mass shootings and
like violence and stuff I just feel like
this game was like as bad a reception as
a goth back in whatever was June or
something worse today like you got to
say that they're probably not gonna be
making a sequel to this bad boy anytime
soon like distance from it I never
touched it
yeah I think it kind of came into a bit
of a whimper I think a lot of people
play - some people were talking about
not covering edge and covering it but
ultimately like you know the game just
it's it's all led you here people like
sort of defending like the game play say
well the gameplay is sound like it
actually is like a decently and it's
like we know it like there are so many
other games that are good and worth your
time why the hell would you support
something as hateful and disgusting is
this game like this is a game about mass
murder for the sake of retribution
against strangers [ __ ] that
let's stop showing footage of it
happening worst games that came out this
year but let's go down the the couch and
say what was our favorite worst game or
was the game that was the worst to you
personally favorite worst like most
disappointing worst game flattered worst
game I'm gonna stick with codename steam
because I adore the Fire Emblem games
and I had such high hopes when I heard
that intelligence systems was making
something like like another tactical
thing like Fire Emblem but not Fire
Emblem and I was just the most
disappointed I've ever been I think
microwaving devils third just because I
think of the bad games just when I spent
the most time with and by that I mean 75
minutes or something I remember just
thinking to myself maybe they're trying
to be this bad but I don't think that
was a case especially considering
Nintendo's kind of brushing it under the
rug after yeah
we're like Devils turd nice heard that
joke before Peter what's yours Afro
Samurai to you it's it's a very ignorant
game and it's poorly made and never
should have been brought to market and
sorry guys I know thank God you know a
game I probably will get a sequel that I
was super disappointed about Tony Hawk's
Pro Skater 5 do you think it will yeah I
think they're gonna keep making
skateboard games and I think Tony Hawk
is gonna be still a name in like I think
he's still Domo he will be the most
recognizable skateboarder 10 years from
now
Oh Shane waited like you know Colin
McCrea wasn't the most recognizable like
use sports person in the world but that
means that iCloud within the genre
Raleigh you know a game has real clout
within the skateboarding community what
state yeah okay looks good
that is a game that should come back
activision love bringing back a
franchise though so I don't know we'll
see plenty of awful games to talk about
this year what a shame of course our
GameSpot game of the Year awards here on
which is the opposite of this make sure
you check out the site to see what we
think of our best games that came out in
2015
let us know in the comments what you
thought were the worst games your
personal worst game that came out in
2015